ragazzi scusate che sono appena riuscito
a fare la spesa online cioè che non vi
ha manco le prevendite del concerto di
adel ce l'ho fatta perché non può certo
dire una rosa si capisce che ci sto in
quarantena per noi
chiariamoci casalinghi da e per non dire
altro
dal fatto che tutto pieno zeppo di cibo
e uno non fatto che mangiare un po non
dando conto di questo fatto sono
dell'idea che tipo la prossima
inquadratura la dovrà fare da tramite il
telefono a 50 metri e mi riprendo e sarà
un gran bel primo piano dopo aver fatto
partire quasi un barattolo di un bus
cioè quasi senza verso i dal colpo di
grazia vi mostro una busta grado di la
terapia di dolciumi vari
niente l'ho fatta sparire completamente
andato anche quella non ce ne è per
nessuno in quarantena ragazzi anche
qualità 40enne che sono affari di
turisti a di maria coletta muove nella
coppetta con le dita si parla mita balla
balla metta a ripa si con me gustan
bottallo cannoli towards alla cosa lo
store trooper nevina cia non è un sogno
ma realtà
[Risate]
va però detto che porterà vita un
fenomeno story fare solo questo ragazzo
tagliati ok ok ok ok dai quest'ultime
basta solo un fenomeno tre gare non
iniziati e mai tu che fai ti chiede di
mettere una droga
se fate per attaccate di ministra
bisogno rosolino ma molto suppone gli
spaghetti al pomodoro
il romanzo di l'ultima volta a mia prima
comunione secondo me dopo lost ea ciao
ragazzi scusate il reti beccate dell'abi
e comunque volevo darti anche un piccolo
consiglio ho visto che in questo periodo
c'è questo virus che ovunque così così
per passare queste giornate di
quarantenni al caso allora vi affacciate
così come posso io alla vostra asca e
piangete riempite dell'acri e così ecco
qua di cose vi parlavo in molti sono
stati buttati e andiamo a buttarli sono
dell'idea che tutte queste scorte di
cibo non facciano benissimo ma perché
uno magna di piume basta non siamo in
grado di racimolare cibo e tenerselo
buono per almeno io e magari voi siete
reperti nonna ma tu stai mangiando di
più in questo periodo
tutte le sirene metà minestrina quel
raggio il formaggio quindi meglio quando
capita loro sono quelli pasto non si
risolve un fallo ma che alleni ti alleni
pure è certo fa un po di squat ma tu
stai mangiando detto in questo periodo
ma che cazzo dici niente scontato
tempo di fare niente sono impegnatissimi
che ho ripreso mentre mangiati è cosa il
cioccolato un giorno a settimana ma ama
quel giorno bello strong e un giorno
strong come lo posso dedicare un giorno
ciao ragazzi scusate sono
emozionatissima emozionatissima per
questo periodo di quarantena perché
anch'io mi sto mettendo in cucina ecco
magari non sono una sciarpa canzona
laurea ammanco basic però volevo farvi
vedere che insomma sono chiara bile in
qualche modo è che qualcuno che se
potrebbe pure via sto facendo dei
biscotti o soprannominato the nella loro
forma così graziose stronzi da pecora
eccoli qui gli struzzi da pecora che
carini sono grazie all'aiuto dell'amico
mio qualche mezzo mia morto cominciano a
tirare fuori tutta la serie di
passatempi dei giochi di attività
svolgibili chiaramente dentro casa
giusto giusto per prima cosa un bel
pazzo del signore degli anelli da 1700
versi km lungo altro puzzle un modellino
di una barca formarli ho sempre per me
una mostra la cls racchette direi che è
una buona base su cui cominciare and i
tanti auguri guarda e qua e qua c'è
gente che sta cercando di rubare pezzi
di torta i vecchi me il vecchio conio il
vecchio metodo te tanti auguri a te ma
sa che cos'è la torta quarterback da una
canzone ritmata heather barbett denizon
paiano
terza tappa del monaco lista con ita
arriva ma mia qualità papa nuovi la
colletta coletta ribery al signor
accomando non riesco a mettere il
countdown
ma domani alle 17 a grandissima
richiesta per il fisico da covip c'è il
corona training che è uno dei più amati
della rete in generale non è
scommettervi il countdown quindi
produrre così
[Musica]
cosa ti un po ma adesso è adesso la
madre mentre stampa italiana e 21 e
flash mob via parlano le faccio io via
via le saux riposati perché chi fare un
colpo grillo a tutti loro ma è impazzito
e voi lo state facendo pure fermo ma se
li sono prima che tiri ti ti ti senti
male come siamo lontani e mia nonna xvi
ha detto conti con siamo pronti a far
ballare insomma ragazzi
vai perfetto latamente city am a una mia
amica
così per dirlo è sposato comunque canta
perché mi sento un triciclo nel core una
domanda voi che vivete in condomini per
quanti ormai a mio condominio che come
potete sentire una discoteca sembra tipo
il singita anche voi sentite solo urlare
e litigare le persone mi stanno vicine e
questo è un pensiero di speranza e
volevo dare a tutti quelli che come me
sono rimasti soli a casa ci stiamo
deprimendo un sacco ma sappiate comunque
anche convivere con altre persone e
tosta è per quanto le uniche persone con
le quali ne possono dedicare siamo noi
stessi
trovo che comunque sia altrettanto tosta
la compagnia capitale interamente a
tratti ma che belle parate maggiormante
malese
[Musica]
vieni a casa mia quando fui nelle notti
più che mai come qui
[Musica]
guardate che spettacolo mancano dei
pezzi purtroppo da impazzire
quanto c è messo a fare questo passo
alla settimana praticamente con qualche
piccolo contributo random mio e degli
altri fratelli ma bob ha smazzato tutto
da solo mancano 10 tasselli abbiamo
questo puzzle da 20 anni
chissà in quale partito siano finiti i
pezzi sono mille quanti e 70 contenevano
i giusti 2060 tira mai fuori del
prossimo passo per favorirlo selezionati
un po di tempo fa mangaka questo fossi
curamente tutti era imballato se la vela
questa è la roba po più da intenditori
ecco qua allenamenti david eccoli qua
come detto pertanto criticavi tanto pace
di eccoti ma dopo un allenato di non
aver niente a parte tutta 40enne un'arte
da uno da mamma eva dopo un po di
training tutta un rientro di zuccheri
farò burberry serve per tentare strong
oggi abbiamo finito il nostro degli off
domenica niente lo levi derivate al
nostro the job saragat si pone notte
pepsi a tutti voi bazzino avrà sentite
nell'ultimo risponderti traguardo una
faccenda tutte le persone che sono
impegno per questa quarantenne ok
ragazzi scialli difesa fate voi me
fallita di base come sta a casa cioè non
è che se esco sa quel mondo poi cioè non
è che senza di me non smette di girare
die cercate di capirlo anche voi faccia
mi sei vicino e cacciamo di woods per il
trainer calda è l'angolo e il cantante
come si chiama testimon talento lo
capirei
[Musica]
diciamo che non è che la sto prendendo
benissimo l'assenza della mia estetista
mi ha fatto pensare di qui a brevissimo
io sarò così per i da carlo proprio
scansate e allo stesso tempo sto
pensando a quanta roba assurda
tale facendo pure voi in questo periodo
io mi sto diventando in cose che non
avrei mai pensato di fare che il resto
però desideravo fare da un sacco di
tempo tipo vestirmi da frida kahlo per
giuro quindi davvero vorrei sapere in
quali assurdità vistate cimentando
voglio condividere anche la coerenza
narrativa del mio costume ma questa
calzino quanto è brutta
lo trovavo a gemona manà manà manà manà
manà texture bene
sport musica strumentale
[Musica]
siamo una canzone per bambini e quello
stava venendo lanciato com'è bello far
l'amore da trieste in giù
c'è qualcuno in casa
storie di casa che abitano questa dimora
sono vere oddio speriamo da quarantenne
turca samara sei tu c'è da dire che
secondo me le vere vittime nel rimanere
a casa
sono i bagni sono sottoposti a un grande
sforzo ecco perché mangiando di più è
direttamente proporzionale la cosa no
non sto facendo la cacca in questo
momento sta tranquilli scherzi a parte
cagate di più e uscite di meno nel
prossimo episodio però la chiamata è un
attimo
ero sicuro gare